[Musique]
j'ai décroché une interview avec roland
colin c'est génial ça c'est à manhattan
depuis le temps qu'on parle de se faire
un week-end là bas en amoureux ça va
être absolument fabuleux faudrait pas
qu'il pleuve vous est de loin le plus
intéressant des réalisateurs américains
révèlent scoop deschamps
je peux plus des années pourquoi il
traverse une crise artistique majeur et
ça c'est un scoop j'essaie juste de
créer un classique avant gardiste du
film morse et toi ok tu es dedans
salut on y va alors eh t'as pas envie de
les serrer les dents là j'ai une copine
je suis pas sûr de pouvoir ça ne 19
prises deux actions sylvie aléo ashley
mais qu'est ce qui se passe je
m'appelais il ya une demi-heure des 70
millions de dollars ces films et relie
en est carrément pas content tu
l'appelles déjà au lit oui étaient des
mois il faut qu'on le retrouve avant
qu'il pikine de ses crises ses kits aide
c'était votre petite amie ouais il est
un peu excentrique
y a pas à tourner autour du pot au chu
un joueur il ya quelque chose de
romantique the art car au cinéma
peut-être mais là c'est la vraie vie
elle doit viser un très gros papier elle
prend son boulot très au sérieux
je cherchais quelqu'un qualité
à ashley écoute je peux pas être parler
là qu'est ce que cette interview peut
avoir de ces mystérieuses sauf s'il ya
du gros lot schiste cette histoire sauf
s'il ya du gros louche ce cette histoire
[Musique]
là c'est la vraie vie la vraie vie est
faite pour les gens qui se contentent de
peu au départ il était question d'une
toute petite petite interview de rien du
tout à peine une heure et résultat on a
perdu tout le week end
ça m'a réussi hier les libations je me
lâche je m'excuse halte je suis
agressive et absurde
[Musique]